all right dream
hi dream where'd you go where are you
from originally um i grew up in
southwest michigan in this small town
called hagershore
and uh it's like a tourist town there's
nothing going on there like in the
wintertime whatsoever
and in the summer time it's uh there was
big houses everywhere that filled up
with uh rich tourists from chicago we're
about
probably it took me maybe like five
minutes to walk to lake to michigan so
it was a
quiet town
nothing going on there and that's where
i
lived with
my parents
both of them my mother and my father
until i was
seven
and when we lived there um
i guess i have to kind of describe the
land that we lived on because it was
really beautiful it was a
a wooded
really beautiful woodland with a marsh
so on
this side you see nothing but flowers
and trees and
ravines and shaded trees and this side
you have like the marsh where there's
like lily pads and flowers and all that
type of stuff sounds wonderful so it's
beautiful it's beautiful but
the house we lived in uh
it was hell
it was hell it really was um the house
we lived in that had
it was a old cabin that somebody had it
had a wraparound porch and somebody had
enclosed the porch around it so now it's
like
one big room and then you have this room
going around it with like
the kitchen and
what would have maybe been a living room
and then another area in the bathroom it
was it was terrible but there's holes in
the ceiling like you can look up and see
the sky my father he put a tarp up there
so it wouldn't rain on our heads but
that didn't really work out when it was
raining because it still rained on our
heads
you can look up see all the
joists rafters there's rats everywhere
we had rats the size of
like i got bit by a rat
so we were poor
long story short we're really really
poor
my father was an alcoholic
um
i think he spent probably all our money
on
beer and whatnot but
even if
i think even if he wasn't an alcoholic
thing still
would have been really bad um
i learned about my father's abuse
some of it when i was younger but also i
learned about it when i was older as
well because i was trying to figure out
you know
what the [ __ ] happened to me
and so when you're when you're trying to
figure out what happened to you it's you
have to go on this journey you know and
i'd ask a lot of questions not of my
father asked my mother i asked
my father's family
and
they all had different things to tell me
and once they told me it made a lot of
sense
my father starved me
uh
food
like he starved me in a lot of ways but
food
is one way uh
and i mean starving like i was outside
eating bugs eating plants
in the winter time there's not
a lot to eat outside
so i was eating dog food
um sometimes one of our dogs they'd kill
a
chipmunk
and i'd get to eat a chipmunk
every couple of days i did get a bowl of
white rice i had two older sisters
they went to school
so i guess they ate breakfast and lunch
at school
they ate during the week
and i was the youngest they're they're
two and three years older than me
so i spent most of my time outside
just looking for food or trying to like
stay hidden away from my father
because he was
he was abusive in a lot of ways not just
uh
he didn't just starve me
he was physically and sexually abusive
but he was also
really explosive he had this explosive
anger like you just had to hide from you
had to be silent you had to stay out of
his way because you didn't know
like what was going to happen to you if
he noticed you so you didn't want to get
noticed and my mom
my mom
she was given to him when she was um
14 years old and he was 24
and i say given because
her parents drove her from michigan to
florida where my father was at and while
they were driving down there her mother
told her that they're all going down
there but one of them isn't coming back
and that happened to be
my mother
and
my mother had been getting sexually
abused by her own father
and her own mother
was jealous of her because
i guess you know her her husband that
she loved wanted wanted his own daughter
and so her mother was extremely abusive
towards her
because of that jealousy like she'd she
dress her and and goodwill clothes or
her dad's old baggy clothes
and
my mother's siblings would get to wear
brand new clothes from the mall
you know she'd give my mom cold showers
all the time like purposely
she treated my mom like the
the house
slave
it was
it was bad for my mom
and her mother just wanted to get rid of
her
you know i guess so she could have her
husband back
and so
she was given away to my dad
and my dad turned out to be
worse worse than her own father but
so my mom didn't know anything
better
for many many years
so she went from her parents house to my
to my dad and he's even worse than her
own father
but she's married to this man now and
she thinks that
she can't leave him
because she's married to him and
and she thinks that like she just can't
get away like she has no other option
she has to stay married
so they came back to michigan
um
about a year after they've been married
and she asked her mom to like
help her leave she said i want to leave
him
and her mother told her no you can't
leave him because at the time she was
pregnant with my oldest sister
and she said if if you leave him
then the baby is going to be born with
uh her father's name like her father's
last name and she didn't want
you know she's like what are people
gonna say if your baby's born with you
know with your last name it needs to
have you know my father's last name
not her own father's last name
and um
so
you know my mom had to stay with him
and then when uh
when she had
uh my middle sister
uh there were still rumors
that my middle sister was fathered
by her own father
like there was nothing she could do to
fight those rumors so
if that doesn't tell you what was going
on you know with my mom and her dad like
her dad he was a real piece of work
as well i guess he'll get around to him
um but
so my mom back to that so she went from
the abuse that she experienced with
with her own father her own mother to my
father
and she just it stunted her growth
emotionally
the way i said i would hide when my
father was around
my mother would do the same
thing she would she would run around
when it was like when she could hear his
car coming up the driveway
on when he was coming back from work
she'd run around the house race around
and hide in closets and and dive under
clothes
like she'd hide behind this big mirror
that we had that stood up like she would
she would hide like a child and this was
his wife
that was hiding from him
sometimes she would [ __ ] herself
a grown woman
hiding from her husband
afraid
that's that's what he did that's how he
terrorized us though that's how scary he
was
so yeah
my mom was always
hiding
and quiet
she didn't speak
it was like she was a ghost most of the
time because she wasn't there for me
she didn't
i don't understand now
but when i was a kid i didn't understand
why she was so quiet why she didn't want
to talk
why she didn't hug me
you know why she didn't kiss me
and
you know i found out while i was there
you know i witnessed her abuse
my clearest
clearest memory that i have
is
not something i saw but something i
heard but i had seen it enough but i
heard it the most
it was when
it was at night
and i would be asleep i slept on this
this couch that we had
in our kitchen
i didn't have my own room it was just a
cot by the door in the kitchen
and um
i would listen to my mom begging my
father to hit her
his name is chessy so she would say hit
me jesse just hit me already hit me
hit me hurry up just go ahead and do it
and that's what i would hear like when
i'm trying to go to sleep and my mom is
begging
and crying for him to hurry up and hit
her because he would he would have this
bible and she'd be on her knees kneeling
in front of him on these hardwood floors
and he would
just
you know
read from this bible all this [ __ ]
sorry i don't believe in god
just a bunch of [ __ ] from this bible
and my mom would have to kneel in front
of him and listen and
after the hours of lectures
he would always beat her afterwards but
she didn't want to sit there and kneel
she didn't want to go through the
lectures so she would say you know hurry
up beat me
and i get it now like you just want to
get it over with but my dad had to go
through his whole thing you know where
he lectured her and told her how evil
she was and you know called her a [ __ ]
and a [ __ ] and a [ __ ] and she had you
know she had to listen to all that
before she got beat so that i would
listen to that
i would listen to her begging him i was
listening to him
beat her
and when i heard that you know
he had these drumsticks that he liked to
beat her
over the head with because he was also a
musician
and
you know the pitch
of her scream
would change when he would start to beat
her with those
and i remember that it was so clear and
then i remember
what it sounded like when he would begin
to rape her
and how after a while she would just
grow quiet
and all you could hear was the slap of
skin on skin
and when i heard that i was like four
five
six and seven
that was like a nightly thing
where my father would beat my mother
damn near unconscious
and that's had a toll on her as well
i'll talk about that later
[Music]
my father
he was abused as well
i found out that when he was a
an adolescent i'm actually not sure how
old but he was uh
taken to live with his grandmother
and he had an ant there as well
and his aunt
starved him
and kept him tied up
and when he would say that he was hungry
she would force him to perform oral sex
on her
and when i found that out you know
there was other things other abuses but
that one specifically i was like oh
that makes a lot of sense about what
happened to me
okay so the starving wasn't just uh
because we were poor
or anything like that
my father starved me you know because
that's what happened to him that's how
he was abused and
you know when people teach you
how to be terrible
that's what you learn
and so that's what he learned
um
things were
pretty bad for
a long time
my sisters i had
two middle sisters i mean two old two
sisters a middle sister and the oldest
sister and uh
he kept us
separated
and uh
in a way like
well they were allowed to go to school i
really didn't go to school and um
he beat me
broke my bones my nose my ribs he
starved me
and i don't know what happened before i
was born
but i always felt like the sexual abuse
that i went through
was maybe worse than what my sister's
what happened to them but i don't know
you know because i was too young to know
there was
some things that happened where
he was sexually abusing
me and my sisters together
but
those things that happened never seemed
as bad as what he did when it was just
me and him alone
um
so yeah uh
when i was growing up it was it was hell
in a really beautiful place
it was it was so beautiful i got to see
lake michigan so much
we didn't have any running water in our
house because the pipes froze one winter
so we would actually
go bathe in lake michigan
and
get buckets of water from there and
carry them back to the house so we could
flush the toilet like
i know every time i was bathing out of a
bucket it was water from lake michigan
grew up rough i mean the house was so
thin
like the walls no insulation we had this
kerosene heater
we had dogs the dogs helped keep me warm
at night
i had a dog his name was storm he was a
good dog you know he used to warn me
when i was in the woods he would warn me
if my father was nearby
um
you know so i so i could hide a little
deeper
he was a good dog until uh
my father killed him
right in front of me
uh it was more of that explosive anger
like you never know
you know when he's gonna lash out what's
he
what he's gonna do
and uh that was pretty horrific when he
it takes a long time to beat a dog to
death
it does especially if you don't know
what you're doing
uh
so i remember sitting there
on my on my couch my bed whatev it was a
couch but it was my bed
and i was sitting there and curled up
and my dad he's
the dog is tied up to the kitchen table
cause remember my couch was in the
kitchen and
you know
he's he's beating my dog with his
broomstick until he breaks his back
and but he's still alive
and so my dad unchains him
and picks him up and takes bro for his
front legs and just
like a like a what is that like a
wishbone a turkey you know what you do
yeah so he did that
and after that i was pretty much
alone because
i told you my mom didn't hug me
my sisters didn't pay attention to me
you know they just like to get me in
trouble
there was a separation that he uh caused
between us where my sisters they just
they like to go tell him i did something
when i didn't do it so they could just
watch me get beat like he liked to
i guess have them as like spies or
something
i don't know what it was
i still don't understand i guess that
part of it
but there's enough that i do understand
now
um
so
since my dog was dead
and that was like
you know i guess the only comfort i had
when i was a kid
the only thing that kept me warm you
know he couldn't really hug me but he
would cuddle with me
and so i knew something
i knew that
you know there was
warmth in the world
it wasn't as bad as
where you know where i was with him and
how
i just had to get out of there
and uh eventually
when i was seven
my mom left him
and
[Music]
let me tell you by the time i was seven
it was too [ __ ] late
it was it was too late
she should have left him before i was
born
or
never been with him out i don't know
what should happen but it was too late
for me
to
to have a chance
so
she left him we went to a
this place called the safe shelter it
was a
shelter for for battered women and
we were there for a couple months we got
an apartment in this town called south
haven
and
now remember i didn't really go to
school
i was in no condition to go to school
like i was starving
i was constantly full of bruises i
didn't even have clothes to fit me
the couple of times i went to school
i would dress in my
older sister's clothes but they were two
and three years older than me and plus i
was really undersized for my age
because i was so skinny
and so when i started going to school
after my mom left my dad they quickly
found out that i did not know how to
read
and i didn't know anything
matter of fact when i was
uh
they didn't even think i spoke english
they put me in this group with like the
english second language kids
and
i guess they didn't understand that i
speak english perfectly i just don't
speak because i spent many years not
speaking and just trying to be quiet
i had a lot of conversations with my
self in my head during that time but i
never
spoke out loud to somebody so i wasn't
even used to using
my voice
so at this time i'm like eight
still can't read just but i'm like
enthralled with the world
all this food like i remember the first
time
we went
so we went to the um
the safe shelter i remember the first
time opening up the pantry door at this
shelter
and it was like full of captain crunch
and peanut butter and all this food that
i'd like i'd never seen before or never
had before and
and so i spent a lot of time when i was
eight just looking at food thinking
about food eating food just
you know i didn't really care about
anything else i didn't think about
what i had been through with my father
because it was so
like the
the contrast it was so starkly different
from what i was living now because now
i'm here with my mom and my sisters
nobody's
beating me up nobody's raping me
nobody's touching me like
and
i'm going to school i'm normal i'm
around all these normal kids so when i
was eight i really didn't think about
what had just happened to me like the
the hell we just left behind
and
it started to creep in
over the years
um
when i was around nine
by the time i was nine i had learned how
to read
and i was actually
put in this group with a gifted and
talented children
all avant-garde it was just me and and
two other boys like that was it so i
went from
not knowing how to read to being
like above the top of the class
and so i did focus on school
like my schoolwork but everything else
was a [ __ ] mess like
i didn't have any friends i ended up
getting bullied
a lot
and
the memories of what i had been through
like started to creep back in
when i was nine
and that was when i started to
act out
my mom um
right away she was never home
she uh
she'd be gone
day and night
she had two jobs
and she would just come home and leave
me and my sisters a bunch of money like
cash so i'm like
nine years old i got three hundred
dollars in my pocket
and i don't know when my mom
is gonna come home again and i can just
do whatever i want i don't have to come
home
if i don't come home
nobody's there to care
my sisters because of the way my dad had
separated us
when
when we were with him
they didn't pay attention to me
i was 8 years old they were 10 and 11
they went to different schools they had
their own friends
like
they didn't give a [ __ ]
i knew if i didn't
if i didn't go home for three days there
was nobody
at home to miss me to know i was gone i
remember one time
when i was nine i had packed my things
and i'm like i'm running away
so i ran away to like this park on the
other side of town and i was like yeah
i'm gonna sleep here tonight and then uh
this guy ended up following me actually
uh
it was dark night down the street
anyways but i had decided that what the
[ __ ] am i running away for there's
nobody at home like who's gonna notice
i have no reason to run away
but i guess you know i was trying to run
away
from those memories and from myself and
just from
from being alone all the time
like
i guess and that's where the trouble
started because
i was left with all this
i guess after math
and i was just alone
they didn't know what was going on with
me at school because i went to school
and i did my work and i was actually
you know the like i said the top of the
class so they're not bothering with me
what's wrong with her or anything and
when i wasn't doing my work i was
reading a book i loved to read i didn't
talk to anybody
and um
but outside of school
i was a mess like
uh my mom started leaving things around
the house like
she'd leave some leave a half smoke
joint leave some cigarettes she'd you
know leave a drink
and
when i was a kid with my dad my dad
would make me
take a couple hits at his joint
when i was started when i was like five
six seven
you know
he liked it and he would get mad if i
didn't
and sometimes his friends would come
around
and he would like it
you know if i smoked
for them too and um
oh my mom she started leaving stuff
around
and um
well [ __ ] i knew what to do with it
i remember the first little sleepover i
got invited to
i was only there about an hour before i
left to join up and i'm like does
anybody want to hit and i'm like nine
i got kicked out right away i didn't
know
i had never spent a lot of time around
other kids
i didn't know how to be a kid
i was never a kid i
can't say i was ever a child i always
knew too damn much about everything
and um
so then i started hanging out with older
kids
because the older kids were into what i
was into
and also
you know i had money too my mom would
leave me with all this cash
and so it just started
i started a series of just
events of just getting into more and
more trouble
outside of school and then going to
school and acting like i was just fine
and doing my work
and
i started to get bullied at school um
i think
for fourth grade and then fifth grade
and then
you know all that anger that i had been
holding in i got tired of getting
bullied so one day i was walking to
school when i was in fifth grade and
this girl had been pulling me like the
entire year
and
and it was stuff that
i mean she shouldn't have bullied me
first of all but
one of the things she said that really
got to me
was um
she told everybody not to be my friend
because i smelled bad
and i had problems at that time with um
i didn't want to smell bad i actually
wanted to be clean but
i had problems with taking off my
clothes
or taking a shower like it was hard
it was really hard because my father and
the things that he had done and the ways
that he had abused me
and so
after my mom left him like nobody cared
about me like nobody cared so
it doesn't matter if i don't take a
shower because there's nobody at home
telling me to take a shower
and um
thank you
um
so
but how could my bully know that like
she didn't know she didn't know why i
smelled she didn't know
you know why i didn't change my clothes
or anything like that
she didn't you know those these kids
it's like they don't know what's going
on with other kids and in their home
life you know and for a lot of children
it's hard for them to imagine you know
anything other anything different than
what they are going through at their own
home they think everybody's got a dad
like them you know so on and so forth
and so it's hard
so
i got tired
of being bullied
in fifth grade and
i guess that's also when i started to
get angry
maybe it started
the year before that but that's when it
really took off because
i guess the year before that i remember
incident
where my mother had came home
this was when i was in fourth grade she
came home and um
she was mad at me for something
and i was being a brat i was
and she ended up slapping me across my
face
and it was the first time she had hit me
or laid hands on me or done anything
since we left my father and when we were
with my father she never hit me
so this was like a big deal because
we all knew what we had left
and so it's like there's
nobody's gonna be hitting anybody around
here like that's crazy you know
considering where we just came from
and uh she slapped me and she slapped
the mess out of me and
at that time i'd been eating a lot so i
was a lot taller now
i wasn't so slim
and uh
i was taller than my mom
at that point she's small she's like
five foot
so when i was uh
in fourth grade i was probably like five
one
and uh she slapped me and i slapped the
[ __ ] out of her
i knocked her down
and i remember standing over her and i
said after daddy
nobody's ever gonna hit me again and get
away with it
and uh
so back to my bully
i got tired of being bullied and so one
day i was walking to school
and
i was like
you know i'm tired of this [ __ ]
and it happened to be a day when
everybody was inside for recess because
it was
it was raining
that morning and so when it was raining
all the kids were always gathered in the
auditorium to wait for school to start
and there my bully was sitting in the
front row in front of everybody and i
was like this is perfect
because that's also
i don't know i always felt like
if i did something
i wanted to do it
for everybody to see i wanted it to be
like the last time i had to do it
like
everybody pay attention because this is
what happens
and
yeah she was sitting in the front row
with her friends
and i like walked in there in front of
the whole school because everybody was
in there
and i just beat her up like i jumped on
her it was crazy
and then but after that it kind of like
sparked something in me where i kind of
just
i couldn't after that i couldn't see her
without putting my hands on her
without punching her in the face without
you know
i remember
i remember her being on the floor and
i'm just like banging her head into the
floor at school
i couldn't keep my hands off of her
she'd been bullying me for like a year
and a half and i guess all that pent up
anger that i had
towards my father
i took it out on her
and um
i remember
i
at the time i thought i was saying
but i guess i went a little psychotic
because i wanted to check up on her all
the time ended up joining her church
group to make sure she was being good
treating everybody nice
so scared
i ended up following her home she lived
on the other side of town but she walked
home from school i ended up following
her home i'd
stand outside across the street under
her window so she could see me
like i made sure she knew that i was
watching her
i just didn't want her bullying anybody
else the way she had bullied me
and then um
i guess things started to get out of
hand at school they started to notice
like you know what's up with you what's
going on why don't you leave her alone
and
uh
i didn't tell them
what had been going on
with my dad
i just said i wanted to kill myself
because that's how i felt
when i was you know
fourth and fifth grade
i guess the anger didn't just start to
creep in uh the
the depression did as well
and uh so that was my first trip
to the mental hospital
before fifth grade ended
uh
i was at pine rest in grand rapids
michigan
and i i honestly don't have much to say
about it except they didn't help me
they didn't help me i felt like i just
got stuck in there and
no one tried to figure out what was
wrong with me
[ __ ] i don't even know if they asked i
think they just put me on medication
and and had me doped up and then i get
back to school before the end of the
year of fifth grade
and
they put me in this this class with uh
only three other students in it it was
the emotionally impaired class
they called it the bad kids class
and uh
things
you know my
things got even more out of control
after that um
i got this reputation of being you know
a fighter
being the violent one
and my oldest sister
she had a reputation it was 14 and she
was already the town [ __ ]
so that leads me to suspect that there
was more sexual abuse than what i knew
about that happened to her
and my middle sister she was a quiet one
so we had the [ __ ]
the quiet one and i was the violent one
and um
when my mom left my dad she just
divorced him she didn't say we were
abused she didn't say anything so he got
visitation rights
and back then you could leave the state
if you didn't want to pay child support
but those visitation rates were still
like
in place so
at the end of fifth grade
i
me and my
two
sisters got sent to stay with him on a
greyhound bus all the way down in
alabama where he had moved
to this single wide trailer
and every night
i was nine
i had started
getting my
menstrual cycle
when i was eight
i've read that it happens
sometimes it happens
for girls younger when they've been
sexually abused
so i was pretty young
to have been getting my menstrual cycle
at that point but
i was nine when i went to go visit him
in alabama with my two sisters and my
two sisters slept in a bedroom together
on a full-size bed
and my dad
he made me sleep with him
every night and uh
i remember one night i didn't i didn't
want to do it anymore
and so before bed my sisters were
already in bed but i went
to try to like lay down with them
instead
and asked them to scoot over
and they wouldn't make any room for me
and they would they just played there
they wouldn't speak to me and they just
stared at the ceiling and i'm like
trying to shove myself in between them
because i really really don't want to go
sleep with my dad
and
my dad comes in the room
and you know ask me what i'm doing he
sees i'm trying to lay down with him he
pulls me out from between them
and he starts beating me on the floor
like right there and my sisters are just
there just staring at the ceiling like
not moving not saying anything
so we stayed with him
from
the first week of june
now mid-june mid-june and then
up until the first week of august
and when i came back to michigan
at the end of that visit
i was pregnant
and
i was pregnant with my father's child
when i was 10 years old
but i had been seeing an older boy
before that i was a
you know promiscuous but we had been
using a condom
so i knew it was my father's
and i told
him
uh
i told the older boy that i was pregnant
by him so he would think that it was
his child because i didn't know what to
do but i knew
that if i told him he would figure
something out
and he did he got he got angry like i
knew he would
and um
he had two of his friends
hold me by my arms while he beat me
until i started to bleed and you know
beat the baby out of me
and uh
yeah so i i didn't have my father's
child
that was the only
way i could see of solving that problem
because who am i going to tell like what
am i going to say
i don't
i tried telling my mom when i was down
there i called her
and i didn't
say anything specific i just said mommy
daddy's being really bad like can we
come back home please
and she was like no it's court ordered
you have to stay down there
and uh
i was just like okay
what do you do you're 10 years old like
my dad's trailer was in the middle of
nowhere in alabama i don't know what i'm
supposed to do
and then when i get back i still don't
know what i'm supposed to do so now i'm
back in michigan
and
thank god i lost that baby
so my life probably would have been even
worse but um
uh
one of my
sisters
my oldest sister had a boyfriend and his
um
his cousin
uh he ended up
sexually assaulting me right after that
uh
that was so i'm still 10 at this point
and um
and i was really messed up like hickeys
bruises like choked me
the whole nine yards
and uh
then school started
hooray i'm going to sixth grade now and
like this has been my life and you want
me to sit here
in this class with these kids and act
like i give a [ __ ] about what anybody is
talking about
when i really don't i just want to die
like that's that's all i want to do i
really don't care about anything else
and um
and i also
i don't know if you remember i said um
like my schoolwork never fell behind i
was always at the top of my class so
sixth grade was starting and i'm like i
don't want to go to sixth grade
i honest to god don't like there's
nothing for me to do there i'm just
gonna sit there and do what like i'm
just gonna be bored
like i know all these things already
and so i didn't want to go to school and
so the truman officer started to pick me
up
to go to school
and uh
but they wouldn't let me go to any
classes because they said i was
a danger to the other kids a danger to
the other students
because i had built that reputation for
myself
where i was just angry and i would lash
out
and uh
so they would stick me in this
conference room uh right off of the main
office
and uh i would just spend my day in
there they wouldn't give me any
schoolwork or anything the true officer
would pick me up i guess just make sure
i was in the school building that meant
i wasn't skipping
and so i ended up lighting a fire in
that room
because i guess i was bored i wanted to
get out of there like i didn't want to
be there anymore
so uh oh and they kept the door locked
and this boy that was also a troubled
kid he was working in the office as an
office aide i think just so they could
keep an eye on him he ended up unlocking
the door and letting me out and you know
they knew there was a fire and i [ __ ]
left i ran home
and it was a long walk
and uh
well the true officer didn't come pick
me up anymore after that
i guess we're just gonna leave her at
home
and
so after about a month later this is now
we're into like
early october
of what should have been my sixth grade
year we get a letter in the mail we got
a court date
so me and my mom we go to court
and um
i'm 10 years old at this time and i
don't know why the judge asked me but he
asked me
he was like
do you want to go back home or do you
want to go into foster care
and i'm like i want to go into foster
care because [ __ ] it it's not working
out here like i need to change the
scenery like big time
and i'm like it probably sounds better
and like
they took me away because they said
not because of what i had done at the
school but because of neglect they said
my mother was neglecting me because she
was just
not home you know not around to make
sure i was going to school or whatever
she wasn't around for anything
but she definitely yeah she wasn't
around which she was going through her
own [ __ ] and i didn't understand until
i was a lot older
at that time
my mom wasn't around and everybody
around me thought like i was the coolest
kid
because
you know i i had all this money i could
do whatever i wanted
and there was no one to say anything so
everybody was like your mom's so cool
and i i would watch all their moms like
telling them it's time to come in the
house and you know or or telling them
they can't hang out with me like nobody
wanted their children around me
but i i wanted that i wanted a mom that
was gonna you know say it's time to come
in the house or you can do this or you
can't do that but
my mom never she never did any of that
i always
was allowed to do whatever i wanted
and it came with a
a lot of trouble because
who's going to leave you know
life decisions in the hands of a child
so when the judge asked me that i'm like
i don't know if my answer had any weight
in what he decided but he did decide
right then and there you're going to
foster care and that's what happened
so all of a sudden
i'm being taken to my first foster home
and my new case worker is going to my
house
to get me this uh
one of those single
single load washer like a laundry basket
yeah a single load laundry basket she
put some of my clothes in it so now i'm
in my new foster home
this is my new life and i have a basket
of clothes with me like this is this is
what i have now
and
i was really uh
the depression that i was going through
at that time i was 10.
it was really heavy
and i was angry i was so angry
and
i started going to school in my in my
new town my new foster home and uh
they ended up putting me in seventh
grade
which i was happy about and
my new school principal she had she had
called me into her office and looked at
all my you know records and she's like
you're so smart
and she was like and i told her what
happened i was like i quit going to
school because i didn't want to go to
sixth grade and she was like
well what do you want to do and i was
like i want to go to high school and she
was like
how about tomorrow when you come to
school
you'll be in seventh grade and i'm like
why
i want to go to high school and she said
you're smart enough but your maturity
level is not there
and i shut the [ __ ] up
because i knew even when i was that old
i knew that i was messing up
i knew that um
i knew that i couldn't have anything
nice because i would just screw it up
so uh
so i was happy i was in seventh grade
now but now i'm in foster care i have no
family but that's nothing new because i
didn't have any family before
and people get this notion about foster
care that when a kid is sent to foster
care oh now they're taken care of like
we can just forget about them
but that's
that's not what happened to me it wasn't
a solution
if i hadn't already been
traumatized
by
my own father and everything i'd been
through like foster care would have
traumatized me
like extremely
it was
i felt like it was put on me as a
as a kind of punishment everything felt
like a punishment
i was on probation while i was in foster
care for uh
for studying that fire at the school
and
anytime i violated my probation i had to
get locked up
and there was terms to it like i had to
take my medication or i'm gonna get
locked up i can't get kicked out of
school or i'm gonna get locked
up and so i used that
um
to move houses
when something was going bad in one of
my foster homes when uh
you know maybe my foster dad was a
little too handsy or something or my
foster mom was
um
i would get in trouble
i would i'd go to school and and beat
somebody up
just so i could get suspended because
that would break my um
my probation which meant i would have to
go to court and i would have to get
locked up every time
i
messed up my probation i automatically
got locked up for three months
and so i knew that after getting locked
up i would get to go to a new home so
that's what i would do when when nobody
would listen to me about needing to move
sometimes i would tell my caseworkers
you know i need to get the [ __ ] out of
here
and they wouldn't listen so then i would
go to school and act crazy
and now i get locked up and when i got
locked up
i would act even crazier
as soon as i got locked up the day i
would walk in there
i'd pick out who i knew was i don't know
you know
maybe somebody that
might think
that they could bully me and i would
pick that person up
and i would beat them up and there was
it's not just beating somebody up it's
what my father taught me
he didn't show any remorse he wasn't
afraid to hurt you
so that made me a different kind of
fighter
when i would fight
because i wasn't afraid to hurt anybody
i'm not afraid to go for your neck your
eyes your head
and i noticed right away when other kids
thought you know they would be afraid to
really hurt somebody
and so
i would do that i would go after
somebody
and uh right away i'd get put in
solitary confinement uh for ten days
and then when you come out of solitary
you know you gotta
they won't let you
interact with the general population
right away like if you eat with them you
got to eat with your back to them like
they're facing the table your backs to
them you put your tray you know right
here
and you sit there and you're just not
apart you're not welcomed yet
but
when i when they would let me out of
solitary i'd usually jump on somebody
else within the first hour
and beat them up too and then i would
get put back into solitary for another
10 days
and then uh
when they'd let me out everything would
be fine just give me a book i'll read
you know i love the count of monte
cristo you guys have a copy of that
because
i always needed to establish
the fact at first that like i wanted
people to think i was crazy
like don't [ __ ] with me i'm crazy i
wasn't
i wasn't crazy
at all but
i used it i guess to protect myself
my mother
i found this out recently she did the
same thing with my father
she would act crazy
with him on purpose to make him stop
hurting her if she knew
that he was going to hurt her
you know do something to her she might
she'd run away
she one time she burned her arm with an
iron
i remember one time i was maybe
four or five and she came out of the
bedroom and her arm was just bloody and
dripping and she had jeans wrapped
around it and my dad's like come look
and see what your mother did look at
what she did
so she's coming into the kitchen
dripping blood and i'm come walking in
there and i look at her and she's just
dripping blood and i'm like
and my dad's just screaming at me to
look at her
and i asked my mother about that
recently and she told me
no she wasn't trying to kill herself it
was she was trying to protect herself
from my father because when
she would start acting crazy and she
would hurt herself my father would leave
her alone
he would he would feel bad and she
wouldn't have to go through whatever
whatever the hell he had planned for her
and uh
so that was her
her defense
and it became my defense
when i was in foster care
and when i when i would get locked up
i mean
i was never crazy i just had to act
crazy to to protect myself
and it worked
but also when you
when that's how you act all the time
the type of the type of energy you put
out is what you're going to receive back
some people you know start treating me
like i was crazy
and like i was just
unreachable
no adult in my life was gonna be able to
reach me so i just kept getting tossed
around
to worse and worse homes
uh
you know i had a file this thick whoever
whatever foster parents took me had to
read that first before they decided to
take me in
and it wasn't
it came with more money so it wasn't the
nicer homes
that took me in
it was uh
it was the worst ones
that took me in
that wanted the money
when i went into foster care my sisters
didn't go it was just me they got to
stay home with my mom
but a couple years after i went in
my sisters were older at the time when
they went in they were 16 and 17.
and my oldest sister she got married to
her boyfriend right away so that she
didn't have to be in foster care
and my middle sister
she got adopted by a nice white family
you know
put braces on her teeth took her
shopping at the mall
loved her hugged her
she graduated from the university of
michigan
here in ann arbor
so um
she uh
she turned out all right but
i guess because she was alright kid i
mean she was she didn't she didn't act
crazy
but i
ended up slipping through the cracks i
guess in the system
because i had to act crazy to get
through it
you